what do you think about the idea of
panspermia that
the theory that life did not originate
on earth and was planted here from outer
space
or pseudopanspermia which is like the
basic ingredients the magic that you
mentioned was planted here from
elsewhere in space
i don't find them helpful that's not to
say they're wrong
uh
so so pseudo transpermia the idea that
you know the chemicals the amino acids
the nucleotides are being delivered from
space well we know that happens it's
unequivocal they're delivered on
meteorites comets and so on um so what
do they do next that's to me the
question and well what they do is they
stock a soup like presumably they land
in a pond or in an ocean or wherever
they land
and then you end up with a you know best
possible case scenario is you end up
with a super nucleotides and amino acids
and then you have to say so now what
happens and the answer is oh well they
have to go
become alive so how did they do that and
you may as well say then a miracle
happened
i don't believe in soup
i i think what we have in a vent is a
continuous conversion a continuous
growth a continuous reaction continuous
converting a flow of molecules into more
of yourself you might say even if it's a
small bit so you've got
you've got a kind of continuous
self-organization and growth from the
very beginning you never have that in a
soup
isn't
the entire universe and living organisms
in the universe isn't it just uh
soup all the way down isn't it also no
no i mean soup almost by definition
doesn't have a structure
but soup is a collection of ingredients
that are like randomly yeah but they're
random
they're not i mean
we have chemistry going on here we have
metadata forming which are which are you
know effective oil water interactions
okay so it feels like there's a
direction to a process like a directive
there are directions to processes yeah
and if you are if you're starting with
co2 and you've got two reactive fluids
being brought together and they they
react what are they going to make well
they make carboxylic acids which include
the fatty acids that make up the cell
membranes and and they form directly
into bilayer membranes they form like
soap bubbles it's it's spontaneous
organization
caused by the nature of the molecules
and and those things are capable of
growing and are capable of ineffective
being selected even before there are
genes we have this so we have a lot of
order and that order is coming from
thermodynamics and the thermodynamics
it's always about increasing the entropy
of the universe but if you have
if you have oil and water and they're
separating you're increasing the entropy
of the universe even though you've got
some order which is the soap and the
water are
not not miscible now
to come back to your first
question about um panspermia properly
um that just pushes the question
somewhere else that just even if it's
true maybe life did start on earth by
panspermia but but so what are the
principles
that govern the emergence of life on any
planet we it's an assumption that life
started here and it's an assumption that
it you know it started in a hydrothermal
vent or it started in a terrestrial
geothermal system the question is can we
work out a testable sequence of events
that would lead from one to the other
one and then test it and see if there's
any truth in it or not with panspermia
you can't do any of that but the the
fundamental question of past sperm is do
we have
the machine here on earth to build life
is defense enough
it is oxygen
and hydrogen
and whatever the heck else we want and
some source of energy and heat is that
enough to build life yes or
well
that's of course you would say that as a
human
uh but there could be aliens right now
chuckling at that idea maybe you need
some special um
special sauce
especially elsewhere sauce your senses
we have everything i mean this is
precisely the the question so i i like
to when i'm when i'm talking in schools
i like to start out with the idea of we
make we can make a time machine
we go back four billion years
and we go to these environments that
people talk about we go to a deep sea
hydrothermal vent we go to a kind of
yellowstone park type
place environment
and we find some slime that looks like
we can we can test it it's made of
organic molecules
it's
it's got a structure which is not
obviously cells but you know it's it's
is is this a stepping stone on the way
to life or not yeah how do we know
unless we've got an intellectual
framework that says this is this is a
stepping stone and that's not a stat you
know we'd never know we wouldn't know
which environment to go to what to look
for how to say this so all we can ever
hope for because we're never going to
build that time machine is to have an
intellectual framework that can explain
step by step experiment by experiment
how we go from a sterile inorganic
planet to living cells as we know them
and in that framework every time you
have a choice it could be this way or it
could be that way or you know there's
lots of
possible forks down that road um did it
have to be that way could it have been
the other way and would that have given
you life with very different properties
um and so if you if you come up with a
you know it's a long hypothesis because
as i say we're going from
really simple prebiotic chemistry all
the way through to genes and molecular
machines that's a long long pathway
and nobody in the field would agree on
the order in which these things happened
which is not a bad thing because it
means that you have to go out and do
some experiments and try and demonstrate
that it's possible or not possible
you